djama pour ton anniversaire on a décidé
que sa lettre attaque et forcément on a
mis les petits plats dans les grands
puisque trois corbeaux
trois corbeaux d'anniversaire celle des
personnes qui vont venir va lancer deux
dossiers sur toi oh là vont venir
prénommée zohra 30 secondes pour deviner
de qui il s'agit d'accord nous allons
découvrir les corbeaux avec une caméra
spéciale qui nous permet de voir comme
on voit benjamin en vrai
vous allez être dans la peau de mon
jardin castaldi d'ailleurs c'est comme
si vous regardiez tout le temps vos
dessous de porc
on ouvrait au fur et à mesure les yeux
de la caméra pour y voir plus clair si
jamais bien sûr benjamin ne trouve pas
attention premier corbeau
carbo martin et vous
alors
pouvez vous balancez votre dossier sur
benjamin castaldi
un célèbre animateur ou quelqu'un qui a
ramené vidéo gag en france
je pensais donc bernard montiel pourquoi
oui
d'accord très bien pour vous qui fait
les mauvaises audiences
je rappelle que c'est l'anniversaire de
ma mère
c'est censé être un ami roi ses dépens
alors à ce que vous allez trouver de qui
s'agit pas pour dire et des mines et des
conneries pareilles non je ne vois pas
qui c'est c'est qui bah je ne sais pas
alors plus vous dit rien lui balance des
autres infos ah si vous avez une autre
info a donné
une personne qui peut balancer des
dossiers c'est qui et sasha sacha le
producteur émergents
[Musique]
le
ça c'est normal et le producteur du sis
à cette émission à succès triglycérides
tu sais qui tu as un producteur du sida
cette
takume non c'est une bonne occasion
c'est toi je me rappelle très bien
j'étais l'année dernière j'ai six à sept
et s'était vu passer non au bureau je
lis pas pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
je suis fier de toi parce que le 6 à 7
et très bien produit et si la motivation
qu'on a des problèmes est ce que tu vas
un autre dossier alors juste avant je
voulais vous dire quelque chose oui ce
que je suis là pour balancer mon chien
je me suis dit que j'allais balancer un
petit dos haïti comme tes yeux
quelqu'un avec lequel je prends beaucoup
de plaisir à travailler vous dire le
jour on a fait un record d'audience
ouais jusqu'au bout on fait des records
d'audience sur cette émission c'est vrai
qu'on a tendance à l'on n'aperçoit que
507 millions téléspectateurs à quoi je
lui ai envoyé l'audience par sms je suis
pas je crois qu'on a le le message
posthume amis
montage du tout c'est comme votre co
vite c'est vrai
rien sur ces rires si d'autres choses
c'est bon je pense au nom très bien
j'avais fait une très belle prestation
corbeau numéro deux corbeaux
entendez-vous michèle mouton voilà alors
on va pouvoir corbeau voilà avec les
yeux benjamin castaldi voilà ce que voit
pas ça m'agace la journée ça vous le
savez dagan sais pas ce que c'est on
voit les cuisses là est ce que vous
pouvez balancer un dossier sur benjamin
bien sûr donc ya quelques années mais
pas en france dans une maison à
l'étranger où on s'est retrouvé en
panique sens avec des fûts d'eau de
canalisations partout de la merde dans
toute la maison est bien évidemment
question obligés de chiens comme on dit
donc on s'est demandé où il était
pendant quelques minutes puis quelques
heures et on ne trouvait pas donc on
s'est tous mis à chercher castaldi et
puis évidemment on a trouvé castaldi nos
propres baissé en train de faire caca
dans les vignes de la maison ouais
bah quand même fini par trouver le moyen
de faire ses besoins on s'arrête on en a
je crois qu'il est temps qatariens à
beaujolais nouveau
merci alors est-ce que vous faire
comment est ce que vous pensez vous avez
une idée est-ce que c'était assez
bizarre
ah oui jma ibiza
a besoin il est sur les débouchés il
fallait faire caca donc la camair très
belle ambiance et en fait j'étais fan
écrit en fait dans les citronniers pour
être citoyen
la prochaine fois
nous étions hirondelles
et d'ancrer un c'est bon aloi merci
d'une très bonne émission
donc on était en famille là bas ac qui
alors c'est ma femme tu penses que
pour balancer une connerie par la faim l
acapa les enfants banon allons cibler l
à lui à toi et tu ne nous as we une
nounou d'enfer une possible lancé ma
femme et mes pour raconter un truc
pareil laquelle obama eh bien c'est la
bonne réponse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
happy birthday
benji
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore mais je pense comme il a lui
aussi mais si la patco bitumeux coup
pugnac ces jeux là mais non leur
prêter un peu je vous adore la famine
arrêté heureux de voir ta femme très
heureux c'est qu'on adore la vôtre
alcoolique sur tout mais c'est pas lui
annoncer d'avril à beinheim marc aymon
ras daniel est encore dans un pea trice
et pernikoff positivité coucou et
pourquoi tu raconte cette histoire de k4
encore non
voilà comment ça va la famille de
canadiens aussi mais elle voulait le
faire un petit bisou
cohabittion j'adore ça la pire crise a
fait connaître à des dossiers on s'en
moque
ça va moins loin alors continental à la
maison c'est un amour sinon c'est vrai
c'est un soleil vraiment ouais soleil
est miss marion les matins ses récents
de la patate à tout le monde il est beau
comme ça au sport il est heureux alors
un très bon papa qui s'occupe de son
fils tu vois contrairement à ce que je
pensais
mais non mon amour tu m'as dit on fait
un bébé je vends ne tue pas c'est que
pour le kiff change pas les coups s'il
dort pas avec nous il doit avec nous il
dort pas depuis 19 mois tué change les
couches effet dans lequel un nom mais il
est formidable c'est avec l'éléphant
bien nommer salam
touati la pâle copie dont m
c'est une attestation du médecin par
mail m s'installant comme quoi il n'a
pas trop mal je ne donnerai pas
le médecin est un mythe ou bien sûr
il sait tout le monde sait que ma copine
mon lem comme ça salem commis des
erreurs il va au sport tous les matins
trois semaines est ce que vous pouvez
faire rentrer directement le 3e 11e
invité trois mois au corps à corps et
encore bosser
comment faire
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que tu nous amènes yacine
comme comptable du cros c'est quoi la
facture mais coûte chez les fillettes
qui doit rembourser benjamin savez
pourquoi des serviettes que tu utilises
dans la salle il confond serviette pour
essuyer sa sueur avec les mouchoirs
second set et
servi 7 aces en plus on ne peut plus les
utiliser on les jette et donc je suis à
enfin le temps 120 serviette il faut que
tu
sais rien vous moucher dans les
serviettes alors oui
est votre plus beau parce que gilles
verdez avec son nez se mouche on verra
mais non c'est vrai avant je faisais ça
et ans parce que je pensais qu'il y
avait un service voilà de
m et en fait
donc immuable de la donne
c'est l'un des gros problèmes d'hygiène
au niveau du club
je me dis où je dis pas sur wii
non ça va mieux
[Applaudissements]
ça n'allait pas le début il avait pas
mal de gaz
ce qui lui est arrivé de péter à
l'entraînement c'est bon c'est
simplement santé d'après lui ouais bah
ouais ouais mais moi je vais comme le
québécois on adore benjamin quand vous
expliquer qu'il soit connu pour sa
carrière et pour cp
c'est toi qui l'a en économique s'alarme
et moi mais moi j'ai compris mehdi baala
rayman mois ne s'est jamais for sap et
non
non non il n'y est pour rien pour parler
franchement oui s'il n'appelle pas alors
je veux dire si si j'en ai plein alors
je vous dire si le sport en silence
exactement et pas voilà et pas sur les
gens mais c'est vrai c'est pas non plus
ah oui parce que lui il est comme ça il
est parce que lui c'est un signe de vie
mais j'ai mon nom mais voilà c'est vrai
ce que vous nommez un petit mot à dire à
bac 2 pour son anniversaire oui mais pas
au risque il est vraiment fort à la boxe
parce qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de dire que
c'est un tueur à gages je vous jure que
c'est la vérité il pourrait bâtir il du
coup
juste mettez deux doigts
oui
[Applaudissements]
plus d'un an que gelée comme élève et je
le dis jamais farrell ne dit pas souvent
je suis fier de lui mais juste est-ce
que moi la question du genre il me plaît
parce que c'est vrai que la boxe il joue
aussi beaucoup est-ce que c'est pas
dangereux pour les prothèses mammaires
[Applaudissements]
non comme il veut
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
encore croisé ne pas taxer que vous
prêtez les soutiens gorge
non elle n'est pas non c'est vrai alors
tous ceux qui sont chez vous c'est pas
lui
non mais ça et j'ai souffert un petit
mot à dire à votre femme tu sais que je
laime d'amour pays qui ne devrait pas ce
choix c'est franchement à la cb
est ce que tu as fait qu'à dire à ton
amoureux ce soir je laime franchement je
souhaite à toute femme d'avoir un mari
comme lui parce que c'est mon bonheur
tous les matins moi c'est vrai ça agace
[Rires]
malgré des gones que je retrouve dans la
douche aussi
là il ya des rennais je fais traces de
coups
et mais ouais je promets que je vais me
chercher des serviettes pour le sport
d'accord c'est celui également des
serviettes hygiéniques
merci